je voudrais explique on marche dans
l'espace et comme une personne décide de
s'arrêter
tout le monde doit s'arrêter en même
temps des exercices de cohésion de
groupe d' écoute et deux postures c'est
le cours de théâtre du programme scola
une formation au métier de vendeur avec
un accompagnement sur le savoir être et
sur la personnalité de chacun des jeunes
leur apprendre par exemple avoir plus
confiance en eux avoir une meilleure
estime deux mètres de la valeur sûre
qu'ils sont c'est hyper important pour
nous qu'ils soient fiers de leur
histoire de leur parcours
scola c'est une boutique école créée par
la fondation des apprentis d'auteuil
mise en place par saint quentin en
yvelines pôle emploi et l'espace saint
quentin une formation de deux mois avec
à la clé un diplôme de vendeur conseil
en magasin reconnu par l'état
nous sommes engagés fortement depuis
plusieurs années dans l'emploi et plus
précisément l'emploi local et
l'insertion des jeunes sans
qualification
ils sont quinze jeunes dans cette
première promotion parmi eux à fès 28
ans opticien de formation il souhaite
élargir ses compétences dans le domaine
du commerce
j'ai appris à me connaître surtout
aussi à aider en vente parce que c'est
aussi important pour courant vendeur de
savoir se vendre en fait
au chômage depuis trois mois zineb 22
ans a appris l'existence de scola grâce
à une amie intéressée elle a passé un
entretien et à intégrer la boutique
écoles en formation on apprend des
choses juste génial voilà se connaître
soi même on prend confiance en soi on en
ressort que que meilleur on grandit on
est beaucoup plus mature relation avec
le client stratégie de vente mise en
avant du produit les élèves mettent en
pratique la théorie dans la boutique
ouverte du mardi au samedi
la priorité c'est la posture c'est de
pouvoir être à l'aise avec les clients
et d'aller facilement vers le client
pour pouvoir avancer dans l'acte de
vente le plus vendre des t-shirts
origine ils sont faits dans le jura
le premier gros jean ziegler moi j'ai
vendu c'est pas possible
non franchement c'est génial surtout
quand on est un peu timide et c'est avec
du coup on se rend compte que là on a
réussi à vendre un produit et on a
réussi à bord d un client de manière
naturelle et où on se dit mais ça veut
dire que suis capable de tout en fait
finalement trois jeunes sur les quinze
ont déjà été embauchées en cdi avant la
fin officielle de leur formation prévue
le 17 novembre